I mentioned yesterday that the degree to
which a porn stars and prostitutes are
involved in the Trump administration is
starting to get a little bit weird and
it's only growing because now adult film
star stormy Daniels who by all
reasonable assessments had an affair
with Donald Trump some years ago and was
paid a hundred and thirty thousand
dollars in hush money not to talk about
it is now suing Donald Trump to formally
void the non-disclosure agreement that
she had with him and in this lawsuit
that she filed she is alleging that the
non-disclosure is invalid because Trump
never actually signed it and as the
story goes there was this document where
stormy Daniels had agreed not to
disclose her intimate relationship with
Trump she was given a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars we've since found out
that yes the hundred and thirty thousand
dollars has been confirmed and it came
from Trump's lawyer Michael Cohen
supposedly stormy Daniel signed this
document Michael Cohen Trump's lawyer
signed the document but Trump himself
did not and stormy Daniels is saying
that this means the non-disclosure is
not valid because the parties to the
agreement didn't sign it now I read
through the lawsuit I want to give you
my assessment of the like the the
strength of the legal claim in a second
I read through the lawsuit and we're
gonna link to it on YouTube
it is endlessly fascinating number one
the lawsuit says that Daniels and her
attorney believed that the reason Trump
didn't sign it is because by not signing
it later if exactly this situation came
up Trump could say I knew nothing about
it I never signed anything you can't
prove I knew about it which is
interesting because it's exactly what is
going on as far as the claims made about
what material exists related to this
alleged affair if you look at the top of
page ten of the PDF that is the entire
lawsuit and some attached documents
there is something very very compelling
which says prior to entering into this
Agreement P P came in which is the
pseudonym that stormy Daniels is using
in this document P P came into
possession of certain confidential
information pertaining to
D D which is Donald Trump as more fully
defined below only some of which is in
tangible form which includes but is not
limited to I hope you're sitting down
right now
information certain still images and/or
text messages which were authored by or
relate to D D meaning Donald Trump if we
can get our hands on those at some point
and hopefully if this nondisclosure
agreement is at some point determined to
be null and void she can do whatever she
wants with those text messages and
photographs that relate directly to or
were created by Donald Trump Netflix
must be planning a series based around
this by now right I mean how could they
not be how unbelievable is it that being
sued by the porn star that you had an
affair with and paid off for her silence
is only the fourth or fifth biggest
scandal of the week that Donald Trump is
dealing with it this time and now I want
to get to the legal part of this okay
it's not legally cut and dried that
because Trump didn't physically sign it
the agreement is invalid I've read some
legal opinions that say it's a good case
Trump didn't sign it therefore the
agreement never really went into force
and the payment which was supposedly
just made by Michael Cohen personally
arguably also doesn't really bind stormy
Daniels into the agreement the
counterpoint to that would be well hold
on a second stormy Daniel signed it she
agreed to receive the hundred and thirty
thousand dollars and she did receive the
hundred and thirty thousand dollars and
one could make the case that Michael
Cohen as Trump's counsel was signing on
his behalf and therefore Trump's actual
signature on this thing is not needed I
don't know the answer I don't know
ultimately what will happen but what I
can tell you is that either way this can
become a major story because if Trump
says well let me sign it right now in
order to enforce the NDA that is an
admission that Trump knows exactly what
this is all about and that in and of
itself becomes the news story and if
instead it's determined that she can say
whatever she wants because Trump didn't
sign it
and her story is very quickly going to
become the new story either way we seem
to be going in the direction where
someday we will eventually get the full
story here and I think that that's a
very good thing the video you just
watched was made possible by support
from you please go to patreon.com slash
david pakman show you can make a pledge
of as little as $1 per month and every
dollar helps to support the work that
we're doing particularly in light of the
YouTube ad boycott which has been really
bad